wir sind alle herzlich
das deprimierende start in video aller
zeiten klar gibt es ein paar menschen
die dem schönheitsideal irgendwie mehr
entsprechen einige eher weniger und das
ist auch gut zu jeder mensch ist anders
es gibt leute die arbeiten an dem körper
durch sport leute benutzen make up um
irgendwie anders auszusehen stellen sich
die haare anlass tragen andere klamotten
man kann sich komplett verändern
eigentlich
und es geht auch mit einer app die
heißt nämlich fei sap und mir wird
langsam ein bisschen zu viel was ich
davon auf social media so sieht die app
aus also sieht die bei euch hoffentlich
nicht aus aber das ist meine herzliche
fresse und wir haben hier unten
verschiedene möglichkeiten um das foto
was wir uns ausgewählt haben jetzt zu
bearbeiten da gibt es ganz viele
verschiedene sachen wie beispielsweise
vignetten rahmen gesichts austausche
geschlechter bärte eindrücke lächeln
alles kann man diese app verändern und
das ist krass
und das meine ich nicht in einer
positiven richtung wir fangen einfach
mal mit dem ersten punkt heran das ist
nämlich der eindruck da kriege ich jetzt
mal drauf das ist halt das originalfoto
schaut euch am besten nur meine
hessische ihr recht zum bildern wenn
jetzt einfach mal auf orte wo zwei
clique seht ihr schon wenn das foto
fertig bearbeitet ist
man sieht einfach nicht dass es
bearbeitet es sind so ein paar sachen
die verändert wurden die haut ein
bisschen anders die augenbrauen dunkle
die augen heller bisschen kleiner aber
gut das ist nur hollywood 2 es gibt noch
hollywood 4
und da gehen wir direkt auf die fünfte
stufe also das krasseste was geht
[Musik]
vergleich dass man mit dem originalbild
und jetzt wieder hollywood 4
hatte man kann mehrere filter zusammen
anwenden
[Musik]
ich hoffe allerdings alle filter weg das
hier ist das originalfoto kann man nur
ein bisschen weiter gucken leidenschaft
haben wir noch dagegen natürlich auch
wieder die krasseste stufe ich weiß
nicht was leidenschaft sein so
[Musik]
vergleicht es mal jetzt mit original
natürlich aus wie duly und jetzt sehe
ich aus wie playboy des jahres alter
seite haben wir auch noch keine ahnung
was das jetzt
selbst wenn ich mich anstrengen würde so
zu gucken
das geht nicht
das geht nicht wir nehmen die filter
jetzt einfach mal weg klicken auf
abbrechen und schauen uns mal hier die
größen noch weiter an ich kann meine
nase verkleinern das ist nicht wahr dass
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich war
das ist nicht wahr das geht nicht das
ist doch viel zu kurz ich kann meine
nase allerdings auch größer machen sich
gerade
ohne dass ich kann meine lippen voller
machen keine ahnung
[Musik]
wie sich dann auch mit vollen lippen und
einer großen nase dass er glaube ich
nicht so schädigt
wir machen weiter fallen knochen kann
ich auch noch hervorheben dass
es ist mit wangenknochen habe ich nie
verstanden dass man das feiert oder so
haben meine augenbrauen waren auch
generell bisschen dicker machen kriegt
er das denn jetzt hin obwohl die haare
darüber sind ja so
warte mal wenn wir das theoretisch
machen dann klicke ich noch auf großes
gesicht
[Musik]
und
also wir sehen geht es auch in die
andere richtung wenn wir uns jetzt
allerdings von den augen wangenknochen
nasen augenbrauen die zeitraum avec
bewegung auf den eindruck hier mal ganz
kurz außen vor lassen sehen wir als
nächsten punkt lächeln
gehört richtig dieses foto hier von mir
jetzt mal full spin eingeblendet habe
ich mit mund zu gemacht wenn ich jetzt
auf klassisch lächeln clique sieht es so
aus als würde ich lachen er photoshop
das in mein gesicht rein
und es geht nicht nur mit zähnen sondern
auch so
ich kann mich auch verehrt machen
was
ich will das nicht
auf warte mal ich kann bald kriegen
also ja ich habe schon mal ein video zu
der fei sap gemacht damals vor ein paar
jahren oder solar gab ist aber noch
nicht diese ganzen krassen funktionen da
kommt man sich eine glatze machen und
ein paar pickel weg machen oder so aber
das
ist geisteskrank und ich bin ganz
ehrlich mir stets auch ein bisschen
okay lass mich wäre jedoch nicht die
laser
vorbereitet hatte sandra meine lieben
freunde wir klicken auch bei ihr direkt
mal auf eindruck und sind jetzt hier
direkt in den mädels ansicht dass
erkennt die app nämlich vornehmlich mal
bei sandra direkt leidenschaft krasseste
stufe da bin ich mal gespannt wie
[Musik]
ein mensch
kann nur noch neben hollywood 4 ja was
er alles nicht mit holly
[Musik]
wir ganz schnell wieder weg einer person
aussagen wir können die frisur bei frau
noch machen kann er jetzt fällige mein
gott
[Musik]
das ist der geisteskrank wenn ihr das
hole ich würde nicht erkennen dass es
mit der fei set gemacht wurde ich trink
mal richtig man auch wenn ich da kann
ich sogar die stufe auswählen auf 5 denn
das jetzt auch funktioniert wenn das so
aus als wäre echt
enno von aber dieses jahr geht
das video geht in die falsche richtung
weil ich real-tor euch eigentlich sagen
möchte nutzt diese app nicht das ist so
fällt das ist so unfair wenn ich
irgendwann das immer mal benutzen sollte
und dann trifft in die personen echter
sieht nicht so aus
okay das macht ein bisschen angst wenn
sich jemand von euch jetzt diese
herunterladen sollte und sich denken
sollte ich hoffe ihr neues instagram
bild das würde ich jetzt hochladen kann
meine nase ein bisschen kleiner ich mach
mal hier die pickel weg ich mache hier
meine aachen bisschen anders meine haut
so leidenschaft effekt die augen
bisschen händler die augenbrauen ein
bisschen vetter das ist doof
dass wir als fanny wenn ich die ganze
zeit benutzen würde bei meinen bildern
aber das macht auch keinen sinn weil ich
mache youtube-videos und das geht ja
nicht das ist ja hier bewegt wird dass
ihr wisst dass ich so heißt ich bin mir
auf meinen instagram bildern
was allerdings die quintessenz und das
fazit und die schlussfolgerung aus
diesem video hier sein soll was ihr euch
nämlich mit nach hause nehmen sollte ich
glaube ihr seid gerade zu hause aber das
ist gut da kann ich mir eine
vorbildfunktion mal ganz kurz nutzen
löscht diese app falls sie besitzen
sollte oder ladet ihr euch bitte erst
gar nicht runter denn gekriegt ein
falsches bild nicht nur von der
gesellschaft sondern auch von euch
selbst ich finde solche apps mit ok ich
mich gerne für diese aussage aber das
sollte verboten werden diese ganze
scheiße snap chat reines gesicht
instagram dieser tausenden filter preset
die ein irgendwie brauner machen oder
keine ahnung was auch mit der pace das
geht ja in europa komplett falsche
richtung ich kann einfach sagen guck mal
das andere die lacht eigentlich gar
nicht dass es so wie hat eigentlich gar
nicht die haare sondern die haare und
nein sander hat auch nicht dieses
gesicht sondern das
und das ist die realität und das ist
schön also nicht sein
bitte irgend jemand von euch diesen
ausschnitt gerade wo ich ausgerastet bin
und dass hier gesagt habe dass das
verboten werden sollte mit dass sie gar
nicht so aussieht sondern so und dass
diese ganzen snap chat filter und blabla
kann dass ihn jemand von euch nehmen und
auf twitter hochladen dass das
hoffentlich viral geht das mal ein paar
weniger leute diese karte benutzen
seitdem epapers gezeigt hat wieder so
richtig funktioniert ich hoffe nur dumme
hat und weiß wie ich das damals macher
von bringe ich meine glatze seitdem habe
ich wirklich erkannt die frächter das
ist und kleine kinder sehen solche leute
als ihre vorbilder an die auf instagram
magersüchtig aber auch solche filter
benutzen bitte supported dass nicht
weiterhin wirklich nur front an die
leute diese app gemacht dann ist es
geistes kann wie das funktioniert es ist
eine super krasser app wie das gemacht
würde wie das alles fungieren
miteinander einher geht und vor allem
wie schnell das bearbeitet wird aber es
tut uns allen nicht gut und mich
erinnert dass gerade ein bisschen an
black mirror dieser serie von netflix
als sie nicht gesehen haben solltet auch
eine empfehlung werde euch für bezahlt
sorry für den range heute
nämlich sorry